yeah hello welcome to this video this is
some one minute bullet tournament on icc
which is an icc Oh Jess cube of course
which is about it should start in about
20 seconds let's see what what I'm able
to do I didn't play a game yet today and
it doesn't feel much like chess really
in this day the hottest day of the year
until now in Germany some more than 30
degrees Celsius this isn't the 90s in
for a night so terribly warm so let's
see what happens French and the dreaded
exchange variation which isn't really
dangerous but always a tad annoying
cannot do much yeah I thought I was was
rather quick but he's just a terribly
fast hope to be able to do something
against the D flat porn yeah some whoops
take that yeah this is nice not rookie
one next move
now King all the way to have 30 g 3 ok
so when yeah this is one of those medium
sized tournaments with 1000 cubits as
prices actually intended to to do a
video on the bullet zone 1 which is the
toughest tournament really young but it
didn't have 20 participants so it didn't
get started yeah this guy doesn't
respond I know he does I played d3 by
accident of course 12 to play deform
young clamoring Rembert isn't too
dangerous if you decline it like a DTM
okay not sure maybe some other okay I'm
just a poner oops 44 nothing basically I
look T to was also good yeah okay this
is rather noise getting the Knight to f4
where it irritates him a lot i would say
you know i have to know how to cover oh
yeah an impossible to cover late alright
so early Lydia got three games on
yes sort of Italian game so so quite
nice with this b5 stuff don't think it
helps much with development yeah I want
I want to get the Knight to g5 this is
the idea so don't mind oops so much the
Queen exchange okay this is a pin now on
on the night night c6 now threatened
yeah this one's even more material as e
79 and everything is hanging boobs want
to go 95 check get rid of my pieces
quickly here oops yeah lots of extra
material so he doesn't resign yeah this
nice setup everything's nicely protected
cannot blunder anything like an only
thing to be cautious off we've got a
stalemate yeah he's got plenty of plenty
of squares left okay some guys also on
for the flood
some really wet kind of line look so
very nice actually for me like it
declined Kings gambit with an extra move
yeah I'd like to get the Queen to to h4
somehow maybe this way Cedric know any
he managed to castle that's more than I
intended to allow really young and i'm
very down on a clock i got a very nice
night though an f for this is a really
good piece no it couldn't stand it any
longer understandably yeah okay one
should exchange the rook to get into
okay a winning end game I wanted to say
this is also quite nice
yeah when's the house now yeah and mate
yeah some guy actually 16 games some guy
huh some girl actually yeah I know him
some german player she 16 came to the
school yes some weird setup with quill
be five I know f6 this is weird I'll
seem to be really slow it doesn't feel
like that but I'm so much down on the
clock already Queen edgewise very nice
mate coming up yep the Queen sack this
is nice all right yeah 3 very often I
think those kind of openings are
basically my lips it happens to me as
well okay this is not a slope he's just
playing this weird stuff
ya need to make good use of my nights
his pawn structure so I'm damage that
the nights will get some sunlight
squares at least that's what I'm hoping
yeah let's take it my teef fer and Queen
h4 so now threatened f2 also threatened
don't know look so don't know what what
kind of movies supposed to play now f2
looks rather decisive yeah maybe create
false even better alright so and what is
she doing she's on a da-a-ate be cool
yeah a lot I'm not winning quickly
really other not that it's it's not not
slow also but it's not the quickest
quickest way possible right therefore
might not be the best but I want to get
something going against the king to
maybe get a quicker women he fibers the
idea
and when I need to keep the bishop yeah
rookie form maybe I know first is
attacking this need to be cautious what
again just just the piece I think f7 is
also hanging so oops take that again sue
me up resins is better or she lost the
game but still I'm only 22 pots ahead
oops didn't want to do that it's
playable but rather risky business I can
take this i think it should be ok still
but yeah I didn't want to do that really
just a mistake um in terms of
anticipating night XD form and still
might be okay but don't like to to
snatch those pawns and try to defend it
can do that but it's in the short time
control games it's often better to be
the one giving the material for for the
active play yeah but this the worst
should be over really know you should be
six I can play next so that I cannot
gain castle also
yeah this is just an extra porn now no
compensation guarantees some rather slow
now you can take on c4 whoops nope this
was pre move slip yeah but you lost some
time still only two points ahead how
much time is left on about 15 minutes we
halfway I will they're playing stuff
like this huh maybe not the best way to
to sky would win as I allow him to take
maybe okay maybe I can get something
going on the Kings side ya gotta take
the pawn and I can take a bug should be
five didn't do it oops didn't expect
that yeah it's okay for black really
can't play book Brooksie for I could
have played the other King opponent game
looks a bit shaky for black I take no no
no no let's play let's play this now we
need to exchange
get to be formed oh I should be able to
play h4 now I'm not so sure about all
this yeah okay now aged form it doesn't
have any anyporn breaks now yeah now I
can enter I'm still in all those and
here i can stop the f porn now needed to
make sure of that this is why i didn't
play this age for it at first i wanted
to get the King better closer to the
pawns all right yeah I'm still being
tracked by two points a bit funny enough
okay we had some sort of nims oh where
I've got a huge lead the development
trying to catch this King in the middle
if if possible now not possible but
still a very active position or should
netted me a rook a bishop sorry not the
rook only need to be a bit cautious
about the black rank so prevent the
checkmate on the back rank
okay yeah let's play let's play this end
game it's an extra piece can be done
relatively quickly yeah resins would
have been really nice all right
checkmate Wow how much is she how quick
is she winning this game this is
ridiculous I mean I'm not terribly fast
but this is insane she said again yeah
and I'm playing this kind of slow motion
openings I'm not really good strategy
yeah it's a very good position but not
the kind of position you you win quickly
yeah all kinds of stuff is hanging I'm
terribly slow nice game even slower than
usual yeah i'm somewhat nervous about
vodka queen here that sounds somewhat i
want to get the Queen back into play
this open this maybe to get stuff
exchanged quickly to a winning end game
yeah let's keep it simple yeah choose 18
points ahead only nine minutes to go
it's really a decider between us to hear
didn't play her yet would be helpful
really
I would get a winner yeah dunno I seem
to be terribly slow already on 36
seconds yeah well okay should be this
guy is so low rated that I get a huge
huge time um climate mo subtraction at
the beginning but still now I'm catching
up a bit this helps come on Rosanna no
but it doesn't I could have taken the
rook also ok this is the mate hmm yeah
she's just too quick winning all the
games ok I need to see to go some with
some some very open stuff I may be
getting a really quick winnin
going for age seven yeah doesn't look
like it terribly quick win it didn't
take for whatever reason now I can maybe
quickly go to to h6 with the Queen Jack
could have could have grabbed the bishop
that's of course I wanted to try to get
this quick mate working you should beige
sevens mate all right aight points8
points behind ok there's some trick ok
just this mess ok maybe I can do
something on the FR Bishop c5 some some
stuff like that 194
94 could be M could be read at cooking
idea irritating the Queen Bishop g4
maybe yeah you can take but why does the
Queen go all the way back okay I know
maybe Quinn to g6 Bishop g4 that's what
I'd be nice yeah this is very nice now
and now how do you cover g2 now not at
all I guess should be made really or
queen f3e to stall it one loose I'm
ahead 5915 it would have been hard if
this not not enough that she's suing
here so quickly so let's not not decided
yep I'm the French set up where black
should be fairly okay it's not too not
much happening maybe I'm if he takes now
I can do something on the sea phone ok
now i can't go to d6 I thought this is
why it should take
not sure even ok I'll hold rock I'll
grab you would have protected it i would
have thought of not even taking because
the light is so nice on d6 oh this is
30-something ahead now and I think maybe
one game to go yeah just for just for
show it doesn't really help much discern
I get the piece back but doesn't lead to
anything special ok I'm better developed
this is helpful maybe I can play a quick
see form ok yeah I still think I'm my a
file is more important it's an open open
to really quickly now oops I can also
take now and grab the rook or the
exchange yeah this is an end game with
an extra exchange now not quite sure
about the clock situation phone this is
if it's really close or try to promote
this pawn quickly oops come on yep
yep managed to get that one in and now
it's 40 seconds to go shouldn't be
possible to catch me really maybe I can
get on off that's just a couple of
seconds most likely this wouldn't
wouldn't finish anyway this game yeah
it's very nice i get i get to take on f7
but most likely it won't finish yeah
yeah tournament over and i made it but
but she really put up great fight need
to congratulate here
no not another game all right yeah this
was this was fun 17 wins in a row but it
was very close to not being first place
yeah thanks for watching